- Please welcome, Hailey Bennett.
(audience applauding)
It's so wonderful to see you.
- This is for you.
- Oh!
Oh my God,
I'm so happy to see you.
- Hi.
(audience applauding)
I promised myself I
wouldn't cry and here I am.
- Should I open it now or wait?
- Open it now.
- Okay.
(exclaims excitedly)
- Oh, Hailey, I'm so happy for your life.
- Thank you.
- We weren't moms when we did
- I know.
- "Music and Lyrics"
a billion years ago.
We were just kids.
- I know.
Yes.
It was my first time in New
York, when we made the film.
And I was just so in awe, I was so...
I'm from Ohio, I was just so in awe
of being in the big city,
doing a film with you,
with Hugh, Drew and Hugh,
and I remember the casting
director, lovely Eileen,
she said, "Can you learn a dance?"
Can I learn a dance?
I'm not a dancer.
So I went to like, one of
Britney Spear's former dancers
to teach me a dance in the valley.
And the next day I was meant
to fly for this screen test
and I remember like
being down on all fours
and just stopping and being like,
"I'm so sorry I can't do this."
(audience laughing)
I was so embarrassed
and they were so wonderful and gracious.
I'm like, "I'm so sorry, I should,
I think I'm gonna go back to Ohio now."
Like get the first plane back to Ohio.
- [Drew] And yet-
- [Hailey] And yet.
- That was the beginning of a
long and illustrious career.
I mean, you have not stopped working
(audience applauding)
since then, ever.
- [Hailey] Thank you.
- Oh my gosh!
You're not going to believe this.
All I've wanted is fingerless gloves,
thank you for answering my prayer.
(audience applauding)
- They were hand knit.
- [Drew] Hand knit?
- [Hailey] Hand knit.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, they're so beautiful.
- For you, with love.
- And this is such an intimate gift.
Like, I'll be thinking of
you and holding your heart
and my heart in your hand knit gloves.
Thank you so much.
Fingerless, thank you.
- Fingerless.
- Okay, so you did get
the part and then...
Holy cow, I'm sorry, your
shoes are so incredible.
In fact,
(audience applauding)
might they not be a
beautiful dovetail and parlay
into how did you celebrate
that win of winning the part?
- Well, so I was living
very close to Fifth Avenue
and I marched my way over to
Fifth Avenue and bought shoes.
And ever since then I've had a
great love affair with shoes.
But they were the most amazing,
green Marc Jacob's shoes
and they were so expensive.
- Yeah.
- And now I have a whole closet full
of overly expensive shoes.
- Carrie Bradshaw?
- Like, major Carrie
Bradshaw, maybe worse.
But also, the other thing that I bought
was a bottle of perfume, which
there's a little bit left
and I'm saving it for my wedding.
- And you're engaged.
- Yes.
- And your fiance, Joe Wright
is one of the most renowned,
important filmmakers in our industry.
If you love "Pride and
Prejudice", "Atonement", "Hanna",
you name it, it is all, "Anna Karenina",
all from the mind of your
extraordinary fiance.
(audience applauding)
Now you're doing "Cyrano" with him.
What is it like to be in love
with the man who is directing you?
What is that like?
- A lot of pressure.
Although yeah, it works for some people,
it doesn't work for other people.
It really works for us.
We're looking forward to
making more films together
and it's great, yeah.
And he's the most incredible,
like humble, loving,
kind, you know, the heart
that goes into his films
it's just, it's unlike anyone
I've ever worked with.
- Can you trust him more?
- Like, cause-
- Yeah.
- If a really renowned director
is telling me what to do
I'm like, "Great, I wanna
know what you think.
I have my own arsenal to
work with, I want yours."
- Absolutely.
There is so much trust involved
between actor and director,
so to already show up with
that established was, yeah,
was really, was really useful.
(upbeat music)